hello
hello
hey
how have you been
i've been great how about you
i've been all right
um i've been thinking a lot lately
and
honestly like i i realized like i just
really miss you
and i don't know like
maybe shit's been tough i don't know i
just really miss you and
i feel like we haven't talked it forever
huh
yeah
i am dead
i don't know i feel like i just looked
back and i feel like we had a lot of
good memories i mean like [ __ ] was tough
to be fair but i feel like we were
really young
and
i don't know things are different now
and i was just really hoping that like
we could meet up sometime soon and just
talk
just talk
[Music]
that's crazy i never thought you'd be
the type to like
you know be tied down to one woman
that's crazy
what about a threesome though
oh damn
why is the end
why is it n
is it because i would find her
unattractive or is it because
what
is it
no are you sure
yeah
it wouldn't happen it wouldn't happen
um
damn that's a damn shame
yeah sorry i can't really
do anything like that that's not what i
do
okay
so you still wrestling and all that
okay
i mean is your girl giving you that good
head because i could change that
no no no you can't do that sorry we
can't not
well
in that case i'm i'm very proud of you
for being loyal
you kind of have to be boy you don't
have to do anything that you don't want
to i do want to do that i have to be and
i want to do that
i want to
somebody i truly enjoy being with she
got me out of a very dark place that i
was
in my life i got you out of a dark place
did you yeah i did
i i did so much for you and all you did
was break my heart weekly but i'm still
here
actually the thing is
[ __ ] wrong with me or not
um
sorry i'm just autistic you can't tell
us all right